- Hello, Believe Nation.
I started the Mentor Me series
to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us
and hopefully by spending a
little bit more time with them
some of how they think,
their values, their beliefs,
their mindsets, their
attitudes, seeps into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to
look at the Dalai Lama
and some of his most inspiring speeches.
Mentor me, Dalai Lama.
And as always guys, as you're watching
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments below
put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well,
and when you write it down
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(inspiring music)*
(mystical music)
- [Narrator] His Holiness
the 14th Dali Lama
is the spiritual and temporal leader
of Tibet's people and exiled government.
In 1959, he dramatically
escaped into exile
and established the Tibetan
government in northern India.
The Dalai Lama has dedicated his life
to the promotion of world peace.
To this end, he was awarded
the Nobel Peace Prize in 1989.
Religious harmony and the
preservation of Tibetan culture
are also two of his main concerns.
(chanting)
Throughout the last 50 years
he has traveled around the world
sharing his wisdom and Buddhist teachings.
- [Woman In Audience] We love you!
- Thank you.
(laughter)
- [Interviewer] In your experience,
what makes you truly happy?
What is human value?
Money?
Oh yes, very important.
Sometimes I jokingly to
telling Buddhist audiences,
particularly Tibetan.
We usually recite one Tibetan
special sort of mantra.
That is, Om Mani Padme Hum.
So we recite and sometimes
in a little bit of hurry.
Then we recite, "Om mani
padme hum, om mani padme hum."
Then, "Om mani, om
mani, mani, mani, mani."
(audience laughs)
So that sound looks like,
"Money, money, money, money."
(audience laughs)
So maybe, dollar, money, dollar, money
or pound money, pound
money like that (laughs).
So money, of course, what I think value,
and of course all these
external facilities.
Those are valuable things, good.
But all these provide physical comfort,
not mental comfort.
If you have plenty of money,
then some kind of satisfaction
in the mental, "Oh, I
have a lot of money."
That is illusion.
Actually because we notice
about a billionaire,
plenty of money, but as a person,
very unhappy person.
Lot of worry.
Lot of anxiety.
Lot of suspicion.
Lot of jealousy as a person.
A billion money fail to bring inner peace.
A billion money bring more suspicion,
more uncomfortable, more worry.
Anyone who truly believe if you have money
everything can solve.
Everything can get real 100% satisfaction.
That's, I think, an illusion.
Money can bring some friend,
but essentially, a friend of money,
not friend of being yourself.
Your fortune go like that.
You become richer, richer, richer,
you found more friends.
When your fortune goes like that,
then these friends also,
I think, disappear.
Even when you want to telephone,
they may not answer.
So these friend are not
genuinely your friend,
but a friend of your money (laughs).
As I mentioned earlier, that is challenge.
That's best opportunity to carry your way,
your wisdom, your intelligence.
If there's no challenge,
potential is over-relaxed.
If challenge comes, then these potentials
become more alert.
As a practitioner, as a Buddhist
my daily plan, right from
the beginning, early morning.
These days about three, 3:30, I wake up.
Then immediately I settle my mind,
and the rest of the day, my body,
speech, mind, dedicate
to well-being of others.
Well that, so then more difficulties,
more heavier responsibility,
have the subversity.
Feel this good opportunity
to serve something.
Write that as I mention it again.
When you feel some problem,
and due to impatience,
and due to short-sighted,
and due to narrow-minded
then frustrations, anger.
Better face problem.
Look right away long time,
it brings more determination,
more willpower.
In order to keep inner-peace,
compassion really makes differences.
Very important because
self-centered person
very certain to cherish
oneself, only oneself.
So the reflection of that feeling,
use word, "I, I, I," like that.
So that word, nothing wrong,
but the real attitude here,
and just think of oneself.
So take only oneself,
then even tiny problem appears unbearable.
If your attitude think others well-being,
then others is infinite.
So think more of others well-being,
your mind open, widened.
Then your own problem appears
not significant, insignificant.
Same problem, same tragedy can be
much different how you see it.
This angle, you can
see something very bad.
From this angle, oh, okay.
That often, you see, happens;
therefore, the compassionate
attitude really widens.
So one small problem, then
not much sort of seriousness.
So that's I think make differences.
Then aged 24 I lost my own country.
It last 50 years now.
Still a lot of problem, a lot of sadness,
a lot of heart-breaking news.
During this period, money failed to bring.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Man] Consolation.
- Consolation.
But then only thing
which bring inner-peace
is my own inner-value, compassion,
and a spirit of forgiveness,
and also realistic attitude.
These things brings
inner comfort more clear.
and my physical health also.
These inner-value really
affect positively.
- [Man] On my health.
- Ah?
- On my health.
- On my?
- Health.
One specialist described
me as a young patient.
Then I told him, "I'm not young, no.
"Over 73 years old"
So then he says, "Yes,
I know your age, 73,
"but your body still
looks like a 60-year-old."
So he described as a young patient.
(audience laughs)
So that shows my mental
peace, inner-strength.
I think it really makes differences
about body element.
So we are same, same human being.
Therefore I want to
share you ultimate source
of your happy life, happy mental state.
It is within yourself.
That I think you should know.
Then I think the best method to avoid fear
or regret at the time of death
is while we are alive.
Our time, our energy must
utilized in a meaningful way.
Serving others that's the most profound
meaning of usefulness.
Once in survival, even
animals also can do.
But for service to other,
is something unique about human being.
I think bonding, the mother
and child, or offspring...
- [Man] The bond.
The bond between mother
and, you want to say?
- Even other animals also have.
But they're, that kind
of closeness feeling
should be it.
But we, human being,
because of intelligence,
that kind of feeling we
can prolong all out life.
- [Man] Yeah, extend it through our life.
- Some serving other people,
helping other people,
is the, I think, very very
appropriate sort of action
according to our intellect, correct?
Or human ability.
We have such an ability.
So to utilize that ability, how say that?
- [Man] In the most appropriate way.
- Oh, appropriate way
is serving other people.
Then at the end you feel no regret.
I've done my best, something useful,
something meaningful life.
Now end come, although
sorry, sad, but no regret.
- [Narrator] And yet, we have been told
to fear anyone and everyone.
A reality, he says, that is impacting
one of the fundamentals
of human happiness.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed it.
I'd love to know what
you take from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply to your life
or to your business?
What was the most important
lesson that you learned?
Please leave it in the
comments down below,
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to John Sonmez,
the Simple Programmer,
John thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
and doing that awesome review
on your YouTube channel.
I really really really appreciate it.
- It's a good book,
definitely check it out.
It's called Your One
Word by Evan Carmichael,
again, a fellow YouTuber.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.